hi guys I'm Greg I'm Anita Tony Gil
trees on Instagram Anita stargazer at
the Anita stargazer channel this was
requested I got several requests to Iraq
Iraq a video but the main the first
person I saw requested M a or MA my mom
my mom requested this video yes who else
requested I'd seems like Greg shoutout
to mom so Anita I introduced to director
wrecker she's grown to really love them
she's watched a lot of their videos on
her own time has never seen raka raka
Tony's my former neighbor oh wait
all we told him was record record can
get violent I just feel like not telling
him very much yeah so much better for
the reaction experience
there's sketch comedy channel sketch
comedy channel alright from Australia
for sure I actually love that show
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa they taught them I've seen videos
where I cringe you and I'm like no I've
seen worse Iraq Iraq the worst I think I
saw was because they did one called real
life
Mortal Kombat fatalities you've never
seen that I never seen anything I think
you have to use especially we got a kick
out we played Mortal Kombat a lot
together yeah and but that was a pretty
brutal they did one rack a rack of MERS
how to basic this what was the worst
I've seen them do that was survival it
was really
[Music]
spoofing santa clarita diet one thing
that I noticed with the reviews of the
shows I love the show saying I want to
do a review on it because I really love
it and I want more people to watch it
but the reviews I'm like the Rotten
Tomatoes score I noticed that some
people were turned off by the violence
but I was like you needed to be violent
[Music]
would you think your first record this
was like a spoof of like here's what
they don't show you what drew Barrymore
is do one episode she eats like pretty
much most of someone
like yeah all right well guys subscribed
Iraq Iraq I'm worried someone's gonna
try to make this dish
no man it's clearly entertainment you
know I don't know man Ted Bundy said he
became a serial killer it started with
porn yeah yeah and this is I watched
porn now I have frosted flakes with
human blood most of the population is
absurd
nothing to do with an individual be
disturbed as [__] it has all to do with
what they watch on that no children
subscribe to the real rejects describe
to the real rejects and get accepted yes
[Music]
sir stargazer Channel go watch our
videos you want trees e is Instagram and
like I constantly point out for the past
few months you will you show me concept
art for the banner I don't have a banner
to like thirty thousand subs in so
that's really thanks for hanging out
[__]
go catch them all yeah Jamal's like this
Oh scuse me thanks for hanging out now
we're gonna [__] throw the ball